ce matin il y à l'humanité les autres il
ya ces dix pages au long desquels le
quotidien communiste fait part de son
émotion et les manchettes disons plus
tempérées du républicain lorrain de la
montagne ou du parisien l'homme du
déclin le dernier des communistes
alors si vous cherchez la photo du duo
marché brejnev voyait le figaro
l'humanité fait l'impasse le préférant
aux côtés de berling ware ou demande est
là cependant que pierre arca célèbre les
mérites de celui qui fit preuve de son
attachement au peuple autres dithyrambe
signé claude cabanes l'éditorialiste
communistes se rappelle marché et la
formidable jubilation qui naît de
l'affrontement des idées car c'est bien
un ténor qui s'est tu ainsi que le
mentionne sud ouest auquel le dauphiné
france soir font écho et c'est françois
justement qui relève la coïncidence
georges marchais notre jean louis rochon
s'éteint quand moscou et l'humanité
règlent leurs comptes avec la révolution
d'octobre il fut le gardien du temple
renchéri dans le figaro georges suffert
qui souligne que le monde imaginaire que
marché avait servi toute sa vie s'est
évanoui à jamais et quand il est
question de mondes imaginaires la presse
appelle ses dessinateurs à la rescousse
ne lui dit pas tout de suite que staline
rôtir en enfer conseil saint-pierre à
l'ange qui lui annonce l'arrivée de
georges marchais signé faisant un marché
qui croît posé ses valises en enfer
quand françois mitterrand lui propose de
re faire l'union de la gauche signé
calvi un marché accueilli avec
bienveillance par marx lénine et staline
13 dans france soir
alors globalement positif globalement
négatif à cette libération
libé rappelle que sous le règne de
marché la courbe de popularité du pcf a
suivi la trajectoire de la pomme de
newton et laurent joffrin de conclure il
a vécu une vie globalement négative mais
il a existé
bref un sacré coco